[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau régis le sommier grand reporter
rt france bonsoir sur la régie famille
de vous retrouver bonne année à vous
d'ailleurs c'est pas plus de xavier
moreau à vis de vous retrouver aussi
directeur de stratford merci d'être avec
nous la situation qui n'est pas
désespérée mais que les états unis ne
devrait pas sous-estimer
c'est ce que nous dit on ce soir le
négociateur russe à l'issue de cette
journée à ne pas sous-estimer le risque
d'une confrontation
le ton est plutôt à l'apaisement ont
finalement tout ça pour ça vous aviez
moreau le cycle est l apaisement en fait
on a affaire à une réunion qui s'inscrit
dans un cycle qui on peut dire a démarré
dès l'année 2000 21 quand byden est
arrivé et que au grand dam d'une partie
justement des élites démocrate et même
républicaine il n'a pas été le vengeur
après les quatre années de trump avec
poutine et le moment clé je pense de
l'année 2021 ça a été mi juin la
rencontre à genève où là visiblement il
s'est passé quelque chose la rencontre
s'est extrêmement bien passé ça a
d'ailleurs été reproché à bail donne par
sa presse et par son électorat et par la
suite on a vu défiler à moscou victoria
nuland le chef de la cei monsieur burns
et d'autres rendez-vous ont eu lieu
entre by données poutine par
vidéoconférence est arrivé il ya une
semaine pour la première fois la demande
de la russie il faut bien noter que
c'est tout ce cycle est à la demande des
états unis à l'origine et là on est dans
une étape encore une fois dans un cycle
qui me paraît assez positif et
effectivement il ya différents domaines
sur lesquels ils peuvent trouver des
compromis y compris le cren vous
partagez ce diagnostic de xavier moreau
l'arrêt plus tôt voilà à l'optimisme et
est à l'apaisement alors ce qui est très
intéressant c'est cette ce dialogue
justement je dirai au sommet qui a lieu
ça a été soulignée avec cette première
rencontre ne faut pas oublier que
pendant la crise sanitaire ça a été la
première fois que vladimir poutine se
déplacer à l'étranger donc c'était pour
une occasion très importante la première
fois que joe biden rencontré le
président russe ou pas oublier qu'avant
il y avait eu des mots qu'elle a été
comme une lâche et il avait traité de
tueur
quand on lui avait dit vous allez
regarder dans ses yeux comme bush avait
dit je vais regarder son ami l'a dit non
j'ai regardé et je n'ai pas vu dame donc
quand même y avait quand même une
certaine tension entre les deux et puis
on se rend compte que finalement dans
ses rapports russo américain qui date
depuis 70 ans on a quand même amélioré
le fameux téléphone rouge vous savez
qu'on avait inventé en 1963 au moment
pour la désescalade qui était un
téléphone voilà aujourd'hui on est dans
une visioconférence ça dure deux heures
ils se parlent ils se voient donc on est
quand même progressé et il et puis il
faut jamais négliger justement le le
côté premier plan des rapports humains
alors parfois ça a été exacerbée un des
présidents comme george bush ou comme
donald trump et mais justement où en
france des gens comme nicolas sarkozy
aimé avoir une relation personnelle
presque affective avec l'autre
dirigeants et je pense que ça pèse aussi
alors il faut voir moi je lui en serais
quand même une chose c'est que depuis
que les démocrates sont retournés au
pouvoir on a justement comme par hasard
une sorte d' accélération d'une nouvelle
guerre froide
alors je dis pas qu'elle est provoquée
par les américains les russes ont
certainement aussi leur part de
commandes dans dans cette histoire avec
ses troupes massées aux frontières mais
ses troupes massées aux frontières rhône
qu'est ce que c'est finalement depuis
2014 il ya environ 70 milles soldats
russes qui sont frontières de l'ukraine
s'est il y a toujours ce climat de
guerre y ait toujours des tranchées dans
l'est et il ya des choses qui ne sont
pas réglés deux fois par an environ le
nombre de troupes russes passent de
70000 à 100 milles pour des manoeuvres
qui ont lieu régulièrement ont
finalement quand on écoute les
ukrainiens d'ailleurs ils le disent le
disent très bien mais nous on n'a pas
peur des russes particulièrement n'a pas
peur d'une invasion parce que finalement
la guerre allait là et les troupes elles
sont toujours aux frontières avec la
différence cette fois-ci c'est là que ça
s'est accéléré depuis bayonne est arrivé
au pouvoir c'est que l'armée ukrainienne
a été quand même largement équipés par
les américains dans les mois qui se sont
écoulés d'ailleurs le pentagone le
reconnaît notamment avec des missiles
javelin avec des drones bayrac tard donc
des drones türk qui sont ont été
particulièrement efficaces contre les
chars arménien d'un conflit haut
karabagh donc on sait que voilà il ya
des armes modernes qui sont arrivés et
les russes ont dû adapter leur char pour
pouvoir les protéger contre ces menaces
donc là il ya effectivement une
tentative d' escalade mais la réalité
c'est que l'otan est présent et et qu'
un certain nombre de troupes y compris
le troupes françaises sont présentes
dans les balkans pour en cas de
justement d' escalade donc il ya
escalade d'un côté tension effectivement
les troupes massées mais également de
l'autre et ça c'est nouveau c'est arrivé
depuis je dirais que les démocrates sont
revenus au pouvoir mais cette tentation
dans l'état profond américain de revenir
aux préceptes de brésil ce qui vous
savez du grand échiquier en 1997 qui qui
était l'homme qui voyait justement
l'idée d'arracher l'ukraine à la russie
pour contrôler la zone et ça c'est ça
fait partie des obsessions américaine et
des obsessions de guerre froide qui
existent encore aux états unis mais qui
existe aussi chez les russes on va les
voir comment ça a été vécu du côté
américain cette journée on va faire un
détour par washington retrouver notre
correspondant thomas bonnet bonsoir
thomas est semble-t-il un washington
reste plutôt sur sa faim alors qu'il est
et l'a fait savoir d'ailleurs
oui il ya eu une conférence de presse
téléphonique de la part de wendy sherman
qui est donc la vice secrétaire d'état
américaine elle a expliqué d'abord sur
la forme qu'il s'agissait plutôt d'une
réunion les deux parties on peut exposer
leur point de vue plutôt que de réelles
négociations et puis elle a fait part de
la position de fermeté de washington
quant aux demandes formulées par moscou
notamment sur une réduction d activité
militaire occidentale dans l'est de
l'europe il s'agit de propositions vouée
à l'échec selon la vice secrétaire
d'état américaine écoutez la
nous n'autoriserons pas qui que ce soit
a fermé la politique portes ouvertes de
l'otan qui a toujours était centrale
dans l'alliance nous ne renoncerons pas
à la coopération bilatérale avec des
états souverains qui souhaite travailler
avec les états unis et nous ne prendrons
pas de décision sur l'ukraine sans
l'ukraine sur l'europe sans l'europe ou
sur l'otan sans l'otan
alors officiellement les états unis sont
toujours dans leur proposition de deux
voix possible d'avoir la voie
diplomatique favorisée par joe biden qui
pourrait donc mener à une désescalade
mais il ya aussi les menaces de
sanctions économiques sans précédent
c'est en tout cas comme ça qu'elles sont
présentées par les autorités américaines
en cas d' attaques de la russie contre
l'ukraine c'est une option qui est relié
très régulièrement dans les médias
américains qui sont volontairement
alarmiste il ya beaucoup d'articles dans
la presse américaine depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines pour alimenter cette
thèse d'une invasion imminente de
l'ukraine par les troupes russes ils
s'appuient souvent sur des sources
anonymes au sein des services de
renseignement et puis il ya aussi des
tribunes encore poster régulièrement et
récemment par les médias américains dans
lesquels des personnalités américaines
appellent joe biden à faire part de la
plus grande fermeté possible face à
vladimir poutine merci thomas bonnet
xavier moreau vous nous parliez
justement c'est pas facile pour jordan
cette position c'est un peu de
l'équilibrisme il faut apaiser les
choses avec moscou les répondre à une
opinion publique qui demande beaucoup de
fermeté exactement je pense qu'il faut
prendre de la distance avec les
déclarations de notamment valu le vice
ministre américain des affaires
étrangères c'est quand même elle qui est
venue chercher directement à moscou le
document qui était remis officiellement
des des requêtes russe sur cette
question ensuite votre correspondant l'a
dit de manière tout à fait juste il faut
pas écouter ni lin les médias américains
les médias américains sont là pour faire
croire un électorat démocrate que joe
biden est dur avec poutine ce qu'on
observe c'est pas du tout ça aujourd'hui
en faites quoi qu'il arrive le grand
vainqueur de cette au moins sur un point
une première étape de ces grandes
négociations c'est vladimir poutine
parce que aujourd'hui on est revenues à
un niveau où en fait on abandonne en
direct avec poutine il manque plus que
xi jingping et ont fait un nouveau yalta
pour ce pour se partager les ondes une
influence donc pour la russie c'est tout
bénéfice et il faut pas y vous l'avez
dit également en présentation de votre
de votre programme il faut personne
n'attendait un débouché radical après
cette réunion c'est une réunion qui
s'inscrit dans un cycle il y en aura une
prochaine et en attendant la situation
et je les en ukraine évidemment que les
russes ne vont pas en verrine aucun
intérêt de le faire et les kiéviens
surtout non pas le bleu n'ont pas
l'autorisation de washington de lancer
ce dont il rêve c'est-à-dire une
opération de nettoyage ethnique dans le
donbass est régis le sommier c'est vrai
que les les premières réactions elles ne
trompent pas à la russie n'a pas apporté
de réponse à la demande américaine de
désescalade à la frontière ukrainienne
mais moscou elle se montre satisfaite du
sérieux avec lequel et les américains
avaient accueilli les demandes russe à
ce sont les réactions des deux pays ça
veut dire que le rapport de force il est
plutôt en faveur de moscou aujourd'hui
moscou 10 en gros a l'impression que
moscou est plus satisfaite que
washington sais c'est un peu le lol le
bleu alors la question sur sur le fond
et sur l'empreinte que voudra laisser
joe biden dans la diplomatie américaine
et et surtout surtout sur sur
l'échiquier international
risque quand même d'être contrarié vous
vous mentionniez tout de suite là là
comment la virulence de la presse
américaine à l'encontre de la russie est
un vieux classique de la halle la peur
kid athlé d'époque deux qu'on appelait
la red kerr la peur peur rouge et qu'on
aime qu'on alimente
chiffon conso conso coup assez
régulièrement byden et ne peut pas non
plus complètement laissé tomber cet
aspect là parce que vous savez qu'il ya
bientôt les élections de mi-mandat que
la popularité de baden est quand même
très mise en cause enfin il ya un an il
a un vrai problème de popularité aux
états unis et qui risque fortement de
perdre ces élections de mi mandat et
comme tout président américain quand tu
arrives cette perspective des mines
mandat quand il n'a pas réussi à placer
son plan il ya eu eux comment il n'y a
pas eu vraiment de grosses de grande
avancée ni il n'a réussi à faire oublier
les retraites alors qu'ils s'étaient
promis de le faire donc joe biden est un
peu coincé entre une opinion américaine
qui sera volontairement comment réceptif
justement à cette prendre au fait qu'on
brandisse une menace russe quelque part
et que l'amérique redevienne un peu ce
ce flambeau de la démocratie
internationale cc c'est un peu ce que ce
que et donc pour pouvoir justement
trouver une manière de dire 'voilà jarre
j'aurais affirme la plainte la puissance
américaine
bayonne peut être tentée et et un
certain nombre de ses ministres
également d'appuyer sur ce bouton en
sachant aussi également qu'un élément
qu'on oublie fréquemment c'est la
posture américaine pendant le retrait
d'afghanistan qui a été vécu par
beaucoup d'américains comme une
humiliation et qui est une tâche pour
manque pour le moment sur le parcours de
joe biden tâche qui évidemment dont
s'est emparé donald trump et un certain
nombre d'opposants aux républicains en
disant que ce retrait américain et l
humiliation et donc la bei den est
nécessairement obligé quelque part de
reprendre le flambeau et de dire non
nous sommes nous sommes là et l'amérique
est de retour oui je pense que il ya un
point positif pour joe biden c'est que
contrairement à trump il peut manoeuvrer
avec le congrès parce que trump dès
qu'il faisait quelque chose en direction
de la russie on l'accusé d'être un agent
du kremlin est aujourd'hui bailon
contrôle beaucoup mieux sa majorité
démocrate que trump contrôler sa
majorité républicaine puisque je dirais
la russophobie au congrès américain et
les trans courants
et aujourd'hui on l'a vu d'ailleurs les
un groupe de sénateurs mené par eux
mêmes toujours tête rousse qui est un
républicain a essayé de de faire voter
dans le budget de la défense américaine
l'automatisation des sanctions c'est à
dire que en gros l'exécutif c'est à dire
joe biden aurait perdu l'un la main sur
le moment où mettre les sanctions ce qui
pouvait vraiment déclenché tout
simplement la cession des relations
diplomatiques comme l'a dit vladimir
poutine avec la russie et joe biden a
obtenu des démocrates qu'ils ne votent
pas cette
7e
requête de donc du congrès donc
aujourd'hui malgré tout malgré
l'hostilité donc qu'on estimait être de
joe biden contre la contre la russie
aujourd'hui il a il a les moyens il a
les clés et d'obtenir un succès de
prestige voire plus non seulement sur
l'ukraine mais selon l'iran mais sur
d'autres dossiers où la russie est moins
et moins à cheval on va dire sur les
principes alors quand ça non justement
le regard qu'ils ont dissidentes au
porte sur 107 questions reçues on
propose d'écouter un point de vue assez
intéressant et plutôt dissonant les
colonnes du figaro celui de georges
guilbault vice président du center for
the national interest l'ancien directeur
d' analyse de la russie à la cia écouté
beaucoup d'analystes comparé la russie
avec l'ancienne urss selon cette grille
de lecture particulièrement vogue aux
etats unis les actions de vladimir
poutine serait motivé par une volonté de
confrontation avec les pays
démocratiques je pense que c'est une
erreur d'analysé fondamentale la russie
a plutôt une obsession assez
traditionnel pour sa sécurité cette
obsession se traduit de plusieurs façons
l'une d'entre elles est de tout faire
pour ne pas être menacé par ses voisins
au cours de son histoire la russie a été
envahie à de nombreuses reprises ce qui
la rend extrêmement sensibles à ce
risque régis se soigner c'est vrai que
c'est une opinion qu'on entend peu en
occident mais en gros
voilà on n'a pas la bonne lecture des
motivations russe d'ailleurs il le dit
un bébé dit on se focalise sur les
vecteurs idéologique qui nous empêche de
voir les motivations russe en plaire les
russes ont envoyé des signaux qui sont
restés incompris mais je crois que en
effet il y a dans ce ces propos une
sagesse assez remarquable notamment de
la part d'un américain et d'un ex
représentant représentants de la cia qui
est de devoir la russie aujourd'hui
comme un pays qui a toujours ses
tentations et qui a toujours la réussite
1 et est une nation mais une nation qui
n'a pas de frontière à et kiki acquis à
un ensemble considérable et qui ne peut
pas qui ne raisonnent pas de la même
façon que les français par rapport aux
allemands par bas mais qui dans
l'histoire sa a été noté pendant dans
cette déclaration a été attaqué
plusieurs fois
a été en presque envahi et qu'à chaque
fois il ya une capacité
la russie a su trouver une capacité de
résistance incroyable il ya un autre
élément qui me paraît important dans la
comparaison justement entre ou drôles le
fait de dire il ne faut plus comparé la
rousse la russie dirigée par vladimir
poutine aujourd'hui avec l'urss c'est
que dans le monde d'aujourd'hui la
russie n'a pas d'ambition idéologique
elle n'est pas là pour propager une
idéologie communiste qui serait le
bonheur de l'humanité et et dont il
faudrait que tous les pays s'imprègne on
n'est plus dans cette époque-là n'ya
plus celle ce prisme idéologique il y h
et la russie dans la rue si l'idée
d'être une puissance internationale une
puissance qui compte avec des tentations
un père les impérialistes c'est clair
mais mais qui est une puissance qui a
voulu et qui je pense notamment à
travers la vie de la crise syrienne a
regagné et le désengagement américain
faut pas l'oublier on est d'un côté avec
une russie qui veut retrouver une place
et d'un autre côté en train et man
les etats-unis qui ne veulent plus être
les gendarmes du monde et qu'ils ont
montré à plusieurs reprises parlé de
tout à l'heure du retrait d'afghanistan
mais ça a été le cas aussi en irak et si
c'est le cas c'est à dire les états unis
ne veulent plus s'engager dans des
guerres qui leur coûtent des fortunes et
qui finalement ne mène à rien et qui
n'arrive pas à terminer et ils ont une
posture n'oublions jamais que et barack
obama et donald trump si on ne peut bien
leur trouver un point commun c'est que
c'est des présidents qui ont été élus
sur des mandats anti guerre contre les
guerres de george bush et donc d'un côté
on a ça donc on a une amérique qui
recule et une russie qui elle veut
retrouver une part de son prestige oui
je pense que ça appelle deux remarques
tout d'abord il ya une prise de
conscience aujourd'hui chez les élites
américaines y compris démocrates de ce
qu'est réellement la russie est un
article qui a été publié dans free fr il
ya une semaine et sans rien faire c'est
la voix du ministère des affaires
étrangères américain dans lequel deux
chercheurs expliquent que poutine n'a
pas reproduit les erreurs économiques
l'urss et que donc il ne sert à rien de
sanctionner la russie que ça ne fera que
renforcer y compris les non seulement la
puissance de l'impact de vanières
poutine sur son propre pays mais
l'économie russe donc il ya eu il ya eu
un courant réaliste qui est en train de
prendre le dessus aux etats unis que ce
soit chez les républicains où que ce
soit les démocrates ensuite par rapport
à l'ajustement la tentation impériale
russe il faut se rappeler que vladimir
poutine fait partie de cette élite ruche
qui considère que l'urss est d'ailleurs
l'empiré russe est allé trop loin ça
c'est très bien expliqué dans les
mémoires de livres gainey primakov qui
est quelqu'un qui a beaucoup inspiré
vladimir poutine c'est à dire que ce qui
compte aujourd'hui pour l'avenir poutine
c'est les frontières russes et les
russes à l'étranger donc par exemple
l'idée que la russie envahisseuses betis
temps le kazakhstan ou les pays baltes
ça ne ça ne se pose même pas poutine ne
veux pas que la france que pardon que la
russie s'épuise que s'épuise dans des
anciens territoires qui ne lui serviront
de toute manière à rien si la russie a
construit trois ports dans la baltique
c'est bien parce qu'elle ne veut pas
revenir dans les pays baltes soyez donc
et je pense que ça maintenant une partie
des élites américaines à une approche
réaliste et c'est pour ça que encore une
fois je suis plutôt optimiste justement
vous m'offrez la transition parce qu'on
va évidemment parler du sud du
kazakhstan tout à l'heure régis avait
aussi l'un des dossiers les etats-unis
apprécient pas vraiment l'attitude russe
sur sur le dossier du kazakhstan encore
un point de discorde un point de
discorde oui et c'est évident puisqu'il
ya voit la révolte au kazakhstan donc on
va forcément agitée toujours le chiffon
des peuples quitte à trouver une
révolution avec un une couleur et et l'a
baptisé tout à coup montrer finalement
que la russie réprime alors que
finalement elles obéissent elle obéit
finalement un accord qu'elle a conclu
avec le kazakhstan et à qu'un certain
nombre de partenaires sur la région
devrait établissements de l'ordre donc
oui la question kazakh ne peut pas être
d'abord qu'au comparé à la question
ukrainienne je pense que ça c'est c'est
une histoire de politique interne une
histoire en effet d'augmentation des
prix des carburants et une histoire de
révolte populaire aussi mais il y a
aussi un commandant là dans la sphère
quatre bus kazakhstan
des tentatives de déstabilisation à
l'intérieur même de la de l'appareil
politique kazakh merci à tous les deux
régis le sommier xavier moreau d'avoir
été avec nous et juste